[Music]
kill Denver's prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I don't
know cold No Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
[Music]
thank you
what is happening to me
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
strong Theory
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
foreign
[Music]
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
team
further faster
[Music]
all right
is that good getting close
I can't can you I got it
[Music]